Jesse quick I knew we would come for me
how'd you know I was coming here because
I know everything that happens I've
already lived it I'm not afraid of you
you should
Jessie hey jar
you always talk me out of it hey am I
gonna try and talk to you out of
anything I learned that lesson you have
something that belongs to me
I mean a little healthier azar I'm
thinking see what do we got we're
fighting Salazar's afters as being God
in the NIP identity vulnerable than why
does he need a suit of armor Jesse it's
vulnerable don't want us to find a gap
find an opening and go for it
hell I have plans for you to truly happy
beginning of summer everybody so one of
the biggest questions I got at the end
of the flash season 3 is what was Sava
tarz grand plan for Jessie quick you
don't say something like I have such
plans for you in the future Jessie quick
unless you have something really really
big planned but I think there are a
couple big reasons why the flash never
really addressed it and now that
sabotage largely been dealt with
they changed the future so unless we're
going to start jumping different
timelines we're not going to ever see
that play out on screen and we didn't
get to see Jessie quick in the finale in
a big way which was a big disappointment
I had a feeling that she would come back
for that final scene and just be there
with Wally like you know hugging him
even if she didn't have speaking lines
so I think they're just like a couple
big reasons why all those things happen
and it happens every season on the flash
like earth 19 flash really cool
character that they just tease but never
really did anything with after that
there's also a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so we still got a couple
season three things to talk about before
we start doing season 4 videos so if
there's anything you really want me to
talk about just let me know in the
comments but let's talk about this scene
in what's Avatar needed people to help
him with so Barry is a very smart person
he's a scientist he's a forensic
scientist he's not an engineer so one I
think that Jesse quick was going to help
him build that suit I should probably do
like a separate video about how the suit
works Savitt are had one of the coolest
flash suits you got little bits and
pieces of during the season but Jesse
quick herself is one of the most Opie
characters on the flash and this is why
one she shown that she can be just as
fast as Wally or Barry at times Barry's
still the fastest version as a flash but
every speedster has
different things that they're good at
just based on the way that they think
the way they learn to use their powers
Barry has a lock down on some of the
more sophisticated uses of his powers
and Jesse quicker just learning things a
little bit faster than both of them are
because I think her true power is in her
intellect because everybody on earth too
is just a little bit smarter than their
counterparts on earth one she's got like
three advanced degrees and she's in her
early 20s so what probably ends up
happening is it's avatar is creating the
legend of sabotage using the
Philosopher's Stone through space-time
eventually he needs to create the suit
one to strike fear into the hearts of
his enemies which is basically Barry and
team flash in two he needs something to
help him travel even faster than he
would be able to on his own if you're a
big comic book fan you might remember
superboy-prime he converted some of the
ante monitors technology to help him
harness extra sunlight energy especially
when he was stuck in galaxies with red
Suns so sabot R had all this prior
knowledge that made him a badass but
really the suit took him the rest of the
distance any of those crazy spikes on it
that he would just skewer people with
they got that message from 2056 Barry
don't trust anyone even me like he was
trying to tell them that savat R was
another version of him but what did they
also have in 2056 crazy advanced
technology if this was the version of
the flash suit from 2024 think about
what it looked like in twenty fifty six
too bad we never got to see that but you
can tell as they go forward in time they
learn more and more about the Speed
Force sabot r was manipulating time in
that mobius strip in the past and the
present in the future he probably just
co-opted jesse quick to help him make
that suit but i know he sounds really
creepy he could have had other plans for
her too but really i think it was more
for her intellect and the things that
she was able to do he's not like zoom he
wasn't trying to take other people's
speed he just wanted people to worship
him in the suit made him faster than
everyone else so it wasn't like anyone
was going to be able to challenge him so
now you're asking if Jesse quick is so
awesome and so important to Savitt are
in the future why did they leave that on
the cutting room floor why did they drop
that storyline and I think it partly has
to do with some of the problems that
they had the first half of the season
there were a lot of really awesome
concepts that they tried to inter
some of them didn't work out so well in
mesh with the other storylines that were
going on so there were a couple really
really important characters this season
one was Caitlyn probably one of the most
important characters the other was Wally
West and then obviously Barry iris in
savat our but the problem is is that you
can only spend so much time developing
these characters so you introduce
someone like Jessie quick and it's like
oh my god we finally have our first
female speedster she's a big comic book
character in a big part of the Sabbat
our storyline from the Mark Waid era but
the problem is is that violet being the
actress that plays Jessie quick isn't a
series regular so you just can't justify
spending all this time developing her
storyline at the expense of your main
characters like Caitlin Wally West even
iris West so Jessie quick I think is
largely a casualty of them just having
too many storylines to wrap up in that
final episode and then just not being
able to find space for her in there so
this is episode 16 wheres avatar says
that he has big plans for her what
happened after this she went to earth 3
to become the flash of that earth in
place for Jay Garrick while he was in
the Speed Force prison now that he's
back she can come back so she'll
obviously be back in season 4 so we'll
Jay Garrick
but then sending her there is kind of a
way of them putting the toy on the shelf
like ok we took it off we played with
the Jesse quick toy for a couple
episodes we started do some really cool
stuff
she was really important for the Wally
West character there's a relationship
there that they'll tease out in future
seasons but you're not a main character
so we just can't keep devoting time to
your storylines so we'll put you back on
the Shelf till next season if you've
been watching TV long enough you'll find
that this happens with a lot of really
interesting characters another really
good example of this is during season
two when the flash had to pay off the
big zoom twist like how could you kill
Jay Garrick and also be hunter zolomon
and the explanation was a time remnant
that they then turned into the big twist
of season 3 so obviously we're probably
not going to be seeing a whole lot of
time remnants in the future but it kind
of felt like a bummer like oh man I was
kind of hoping there'd be a more
sophisticated explanation for how he was
able to do this and I think that was
mostly in the name of simplicity so in
the comics there are a number of times
that the flash has appeared but it's
been someone else pretending to be
another person when Barry Allen died
during crisis on Infinite Earths later
there was a period of the Mark Waid
comics where Barry Allen came back but
it was secretly eobard thawne pretending
to be Barry but you can't really do that
on the TV show because like look at Matt
Letcher here this is what he looks like
next to Grant Gustin it would be so hard
for him to wear a Grant Gustin mask and
masquerade is baryon so it's kind of the
same thing with the time remnants of
season two and they kind of fixed that
with the face changing device during
season three now you have a way around
that but little twist like that they
don't figure that out at the beginning
of the season so at the beginning of
season three they knew they wanted to do
this avatar berry twist but they didn't
know how that would play out and how it
would affect the other characters so a
lot of times when you get to the point
where you actually have to explain all
these big plot points that you set up
it doesn't always quite work out so
things get left on the floor one of
those big things this season was Jesse
quick which kind of sucks but she'll be
back with a really cool story in season
for pretty much every really cool
character that you like always comes
back even if it's only a little bit what
I'll probably do for my next video is
more speedsters that they could
introduce during season four there's a
literally an infinite number of
speedsters they could bring on the show
Multiversity earth 19 flash is a good
example of just really obscure people
even if they don't have big comic book
stories that they can tease and funny
ways on the TV show so leave all your
requests for bonus videos but I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Matthew McKinney please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video announced the winner the next time
I post a DC video I do have some new
Justice League that I'm going to be
posting later today so I'll try to get
that out as fast as possible you can
click here for all my season 4
predictions and you can click here to
start getting ready for Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight